now you're tiny and weak and I'm the
opposite so the objective of this
exercise is to get past me now a good
idea might be to cause the distraction
because otherwise there'd be zero chance
[Applause]
someone told me that Dave got a little
too intense on set that you know there
might have been a swear jar oh you know
actually he was swearing swearing
earlier backstage and I have that you
contributed to that jar they got to the
point where I was just like I was paying
her so much I needed credit yeah cuz I
know I don't know maybe half of it maybe
half of maybe not the hundred bucks or
so it was like - it was like two dollars
a cuss word then that was like five
bucks yeah see I tell my kids you can
curse like mommy when you pay your bills
like mommy you can say whatever you'd
like
we're Inc yeah we're all I mean we're
okay with it cuz we knew we were all
aware that there was children on set we
need to be better about it was just
something that guess what you're in a
rhythm of speaking a certain way
throughout your life yeah it's hard to
can you know continue control but we you
know we've made an effort she donated
all the money yeah I donated it to the
Amazon rainforest because you know what
it's set on fire it was like
256 dollars that's how many people were
swearing on set I was I was like really
gonna be this like how hard is it it is
so hard
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going